oh que oui accueillir par là dessus on a
trop simple et j'adore ce tabouret c'est
grâce à ce tabouret que je passais dans
youtube une vidéo très apprécié alors
aujourd'hui ancien président qui est pas
comme ce qu'on fait d'habitude c'est un
seul résident bon mood bas ce qu'on fait
d'habitude sont pas mauvais mouthe mais
la laque c'est vraiment bon mood c'est
des trucs un peu qui font plaisir dioman
gbagbo comme son nom l'indiqué c'est des
humains qui se comportent comme des
frères qui se comportent hyper bien qui
sont hyper bienveillant talentueux qui
se mouillent qui bref c'est vraiment que
des trucs cool et agréable à regarder
qui font du bien vous avez déjà dû voir
pas mal de vidéos de gens là il y en a
pas mal qui tombe sur les réseaux
sociaux et c'est souvent des vidéos
genre ou c'est un animal qui est secouru
et il le soigne puis lui trouve une
famille etc
ou alors il y aussi les vidéos de juge
ou cd juges qui sont hyper indulgent
avec la personne qu'ils ont en face et
je précise
j'ai un blème avec les vidéos comme ça
genre de 20 secondes où on voit
quelqu'un pleurer être ému aux larmes et
tout ça me touche profondément et j'ai
naturellement envie de pleurer quand je
vois ça je sais pas pourquoi je me
retiens parce que je sais pas j'ai une
sorte de fierté bizarre mal placé
j'aurai je vais pas pleurer devant un
film ou une vidéo s et de l'huile ça
fait du bien de me rendre mais je vous
jure que je suis capable de pleurer
comme ça sur une vidéo de huit secondes
quoi c'est un peu touche trop bon en
tout cas je vais essayer de pas pleurer
puis voilà ça veut faire du bien en vrai
ça nous faire du bien tout donner à ces
petits trucs c'est parti un livreur dhl
qui cache mon colis derrière un pilier
quand il livre et qui voit que j'ai été
livré plus tôt et qui décide de cacher
ce paquet là aussi à paris mais pour
ceux qui ont vu la vidéo là au regard
des vidéos ring vous savez aux us donc
tous les colis sont beaucoup volé et du
coup les livreurs cool cache le colis
qui te livre derrière un pilier de chez
toi il faut avoir un pilier c'est le
problème on après tout ces piliers très
agréable de voir des livreurs comme ça
on aimerait beaucoup plus vraiment
beaucoup plus chronopost si vous
regardez cette vidéo fait un effort les
frérots c'est arrivé la nuit dernière à
montbard
attends kouakou kouakou un pote je vois
un gars qui compte j'ai rien compris
excusez moi ça va vite
ok je crois que ce gars là a un problème
ok il était en train de s'étouffer il
fait la fameuse technique ok hu et en
plus tu fais un petit massage gratos au
niveau des épaules très agréable ce
barman
alors oui il y à vraiment lui sauver la
vie je sais qu'on oublie on attend c'est
oublié mais ya beaucoup de gens qui
meurent chaque année dans des accidents
domestiques et accidents domestiques ça
c'est des trucs une nulle comme ça c'est
tout fait changer une ampoule et se
prendre un coup de jus tomber dans sa
cuisine c'est des trucs nul et a
beaucoup de morts le chiffre s'affiche
ici c'est horrible du coup les gestes de
premiers secours c'est hyper cool de les
connecter à chaque fois je les apprends
à chaque fois je les oublie à chaque
fois je tombe sur une vidéo comme ça et
du coup je dirais apprend alors lèverait
étape s'affiche ici que vous êtes
beaucoup à regarder les vidéos
profitons-en voilà si jamais vous voulez
quelqu'un s'étouffe et vous serez quoi
faire un chauffeur de bus très cool qui
prévient le deux roues qu'un piéton
traverse à à tous et que font ils de
roue je crois savoir ce que c'est cette
situation tous ceux qui font du deux
roues vous savez waouh tout le monde est
si gentil tout le monde est si gentil
dans cette vidéo le piéton qui prend
soin de bien regarder ils allaient même
laissé passer la moto la moto qui pilent
parce qu elle s'enquiert un petit truc
qui arrive le chauffeur de bus qui
prévient [ __ ] on n'a pas les mêmes
humains si vous êtes piétons fait gaffe
s'il vous plaît je suis en mode
moralisateur je suis un supporter a fait
attention vraiment je dis ça pour vous
quand vous traversez une route comme ça
parce que il ya très souvent des deux
roues en double file et il ya plein de
piétons qui n'ont pas conscience qu'à
des deux roues en double file et qui se
font faucher tous les jours mais
vraiment donc faite grâce à vous la
prenez soin de vous les gagnants de la
deuxième et troisième place
ed le gagnant pour la photo quoi j'ai
rien compris
ok
pas parce qu'il est petit ils vont faire
quoi qu'est ce qu'ils font non mais dis
pas non qu'est-ce qui est le plus
humiliant et je peux parler je suis armé
70 que ça se voit sur la photo que tu es
petit ou que ça se voit sur la photo que
tu es petit parce qu'on voit tes voisins
de portée ils n'ont pas du tout aidé ils
ont juste la haine parce qu'il est
premier avec eux et sont deuxièmes et
troisièmes ils ont décidé de l'humilier
à leur manière respectez les petits
[ __ ] et les gauchers aussi à tort un
manifestant qui tient un parapluie un
journaliste on n'a pas fait même du mas
des amis vous voyez ça vous allez
vraiment lui mettre un parapluie vous
allez faire le signe de giulia croda mon
grand-père a écrit un livre à propos de
sa vie avant qu'il meure quelques années
plus tard ma grand-mère de 93 ans a
perdu la vue et ne peut plus lire donc
j'ai fait un odieux book pour elle elle
n'avait pas compris que j'avais
enregistrée tout le livre j'ai envie de
pleurer mais je suis faible ça me touche
trop les personnes âgées comme ça qu'on
leur fait un cadeau incroyable ça me
fait trop quelque chose de voir des
réactions de gens genre trop émue aux
larmes
je pleure avec eux je vous jure c'est
dur un nouveau première année à
l'université se faisait harceler parce
qu'ils portaient tous les jours les
mêmes vêtements
du coup ses camarades de classe ont
décidé lui acheter de nouveaux vêtements
une nouvelle paire de chaussures
mais non alors là c'est vraiment un
grand m mais non c'est incroyable
aux essais par réagir il est trop mignon
et enrichir il est trop content mais il
n'arrive pas à le montrer dé gêner or il
lui fait un check
alors ça franchement c'est trop bien
mais faire salle à tendre la main vers
le gars plutôt que de rejoindre le
groupe qui harcèle pour se sentir
puissant c'est magnifique
hmm pas quoi dire je suis stupéfait je
trouve ça fou un si jeune âge de faire
ce à quoi déjà ne pas rentrer dans le
groupe qui harcèlent passe car il ya un
âge où tu comprends pas quel point c'est
grave et horrible de faire ça mais en
plus tendre la main comme ça vingt sur
vingt fait ça on en passe à un an je
crois savoir ce que c'est j'en ai vu
passer choix déjà aussi des comme ça il
y a un an ma petite soeur a quitté ce
monde ce week-end le bénéficiaire de la
greffe de son coeur a rencontré ma mère
et à partager avec elles les battements
de son coeur
or c'est fort je vais pas pleurer ce
n'est pas une vidéo mais si c'est une
vidéo j'aurais clairement pleurer oh non
c'est trop mignon c'est un jeune qui
était sur le chemin d'un entretien
d'embauché et qui galérait affaires sont
des cravates et du coup la dame en rouge
l'a vu elle a demandé à son mari lui
faire sans de travail
tiens ça fait plaisir je vous mets le
lien descriptions faites un tour là tu
devais vous n'êtes pas bien fait un tour
là dessus ça fait du bien je vous jure
quoi incroyable tarn après les trucs
fous il ya une application qui s'appelle
be my eyes et qui permet aux gens
aveugles de recevoir de l'aide de jean
pas aveugle via un facetime en fait un
appel facetime ne sais pas moi genre
s'ils trouvent pas leur route s'ils
comprennent pas où ils sont enfin j'en
sais rien tous ces trucs là quoi et la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'en une journée
il ya 112 mille personnes qui font appel
à ce service et 1 million 800 mille
volontaires trop bien les trucs
d'entr'aide comme ça c'est poids à j'ai
vu celle l incroyable ça c'est un crabe
c'est un mec qui va sauver son chien
j'ai déjà vu de québec sa maison elle a
pris feu il arrive en courant dans la
maison il y va et samba les couilles
donc à les pompiers sont en pls et se
disent mes gros il va mourir [ __ ] on
fait comment il ya vraiment des flammes
de quatre mètres la dent dans la maison
il est de retour il va bien vous en
faites pas en fait il est juste aller
sauver son chien parce que son chien
était enfermé dans une pièce de la
maison et ils le gardent une interview
derrière il a expliqué il s'est brûlé
tout le bras l'épaule gauche et pas
qu'en 20e degrés mais il voulait
absolument sauver son chien quoi c'est
ouf c'est trop beau et en vrai tout ce
qu'on des chiens vous comprenez
parfaitement cette action j'en suis
certain non non non non
en fait j'ai plus envie là ça me rend
heureux et triste à la fois trop
d'émotions bizarre qui signifie qu'à
qu'une béquille c'est compliqué avec une
seul métier
[Musique]
waouh
et à langen en plus au passage elle lui
a mis un petit taquet trop bien je suis
sûr qu'ils aralis gros bâtards suis sûr
qu'il a râlé pardon j'ai la haine en moi
la non au hockey donc c'est un vétéran
qui a perdu ses chiens parce qu'il a été
hospitalisé qu'il avait personne pour
s'occuper de ses chiens sauf que du coup
dans ces cas là il ya des associations
comme en l'occurrence petsmart qui
récupère les animaux qui sont occupés et
qui attendent que le propriétaire
sortent de l'hôpital et viennent les
récupérer mais on échange propriétaire
doit donner un peu d'argent qui
correspondent aux frais de vétérinaire
aux croquettes donnés aux animaux etc
hélas en venant récupérer ces animaux ce
monsieur s'est rendu compte que les
employés petsmart ont payé pour lui la
taxe au nord la ja le combo animaux
personnes âgées et bienveillance ça va
me tuer elle en train de lui expliquer
du couquet qu'ils ont payé pour lui et
qui peut les récupérer
non
[Musique]
au nom prononcé
s'il ya le moment où il revoit ses
chiens je suis morte
[Musique]
ouah ouah là c'est dur voilà c'est ça
c'est ce dodo voilà et c'est eux qui
font les vidéos là sur les animaux tout
le temps où ils récupèrent où il est
soigné je veux plus voir ça j'en ai
marre et film emmène slate
excusez moi je les regardais [ __ ] je
suis obligé sa matière trop un chien de
16 ans n'arrive plus à très bien marché
mais il aime jouer dans la neige donc
son propriétaire l'aide à prendre ce
petit plaisir
ah ah ah ah ah ah si l'homme était un
peu plus vif j'aurais pleuré
bah c'est trop beau c'est génial c'est
trop trop bien
un groupe d'adolescents qui ce qui a
sauvé un enfant sur la montagne
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui s'est passé je
veux tout savoir s'il vous plaît aux
merde watts
comment il a fait ils sont mis en bas
ils l'ont rattrapé tous ensemble c'est
ça ou pas aux malades
saleh a amorti vous pensez tiens
pourquoi on n'a pas le plan lui la lengo
pro là je suis horrible waouh il a pas
l'air de se relever mais wahaha
peter beau gosse mois un combattant aide
son adversaire à se replacer les pôles
qu'est ce que c'est que ce fair play en
norme mon gars moi on m'accuse d'être
loups garous et insulte tout le monde
lui re place les pôles son adversaire à
temps
[Musique]
quoi et là ils vont se battre
fois pour ça que je me mets à trop aimer
le sport regarder ses valeurs ses beaux
attend quoi
le black friday au canada à tout instant
j'ai cru voir un truc on dirait une
vague
on dirait une vanne c'est des joueurs qu
écrit un sketch ça mais mon gars ça se
passe jamais comme ça c'est après envoi
je vois une vidéo du black friday où il
ya autant de monde et que tout le monde
et il est calme on dirait une autre
dimension c'est bizarre bon écoute et à
ses deux de bonnes choses pour
aujourd'hui c'était très agréable fut
très content beaucoup de trucs cool
beaucoup de bonnes actions beaucoup de
gens bienveillants ça fait beaucoup de
bien c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
négatif est beaucoup plus facilement
parler de lui par rapport au positif
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il ya pas de
positif ça veut juste dire que y en a et
qu'il faut le chercher parce que les
gens moins tendance à le relayer partout
que le négatif mais il ya beaucoup de
positif des taxes aux ardennais des
petites idées aussi pourquoi pas fait
tout coule autour de vous et puis quand
bien même celle ci vous aura fait du
bien et relativiser sur des choses moi
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à faire un
tour ya bla bla bla bla les postes sur
celui là je vous dis à bientôt je vous
souhaite du coup plein de bonnes choses
a très vite je suis refuge trop content
[Musique]
à bord
m
[Musique]